tras otra noche de intensos bombardeos a
la estratégica ciudad oriental de
severodonezk está ahora casi totalmente
bajo control ruso las fuerzas ucranianas
que habían resistido el avance de moscú
durante semanas se vieron obligadas a
retirarse del centro de la ciudad el
lunes ayudado por el apoyo de la
artillería el enemigo llevó a cabo
operaciones en la ciudad de severodonezk
han tenido un éxito parcial y empujaron
a nuestras tropas fuera del centro de la
ciudad los combates continúan unos 500
civiles ucranianos y otros tantos
soldados seguían atrincherados dentro de
la planta química us.es de severodonezk
en un escenario que recuerda el
sangriento asedio de mariupol severo
donges que representa un objetivo
estratégico clave para moscú que busca
establecer el control sobre la región
oriental ucraniana de lumbar mientras se
combate en múltiples frentes al domingo
rusia disparó una serie de cohetes sobre
la ciudad de sorkin y afirmó haber
destruido un almacén que contenía armas
suministradas por eeuu y europa
los misiles de alta precisión
destruyeron un gran número de armas y
equipos militares
llegados a los grupos nacionalistas
ucranianos incluyendo algunos de eeuu y
europa
funcionarios ucranianos confirmaron que
los cohetes rusos alcanzaron una
instalación militar en la zona pero
dijeron que no había armas almacenadas
allí mientras tanto quien pidió más
entregas de armas pesadas incluyendo
tanques drones y lanzacohetes antes de
una reunión prevista de los ministros de
defensa occidentales el 15 de junio